do you know that I do not play the
lottery cuz I'm scared to win you're
scared when I do not play the lottery
because I'm scared to win because then
everybody will say that it was the
lottery ticket that enabled me to do the
things I'm planning on doing the next 50
years
easy money scares you though 100 percent
yep I think it's the first time I've
ever said it's the first time I've said
it out loud
you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
what's the question be the way the
person decides to judge it you know like
it's just the way you decide to judge it
right like like I want to be the most
successful business person of all time
but I decided to judge that as impacting
other people not making the most money
you know like what's a successful
creative everybody in the world seeing
it for 10,000 people being changed by it
it just comes down to how you judge
around school take yourself I love your
hair by the way that's a question I've
been thinking about this about you for a
minute
like every time I see you at the knick
games I'm always like I can't like love
business so much it's all I think about
kind of I think you're a really unique
dude from Astana on something like I
think you're ranking ranking like
arbitrary ranking in culture is is
really high
oh uh like when I say that does that
make sense to you like I think people
[ __ ] with you way bigger than the way
you're playing right now and so when I
watch it no they my brother you tell a
lot of you would said what I just and I
was like oh by the way by the way that's
that's fine I'm talking about like
thoughtfully thinking about like the
actual opportunities that you could have
I have no idea what the [ __ ] you care
about but I can tell you one thing there
what I'm good at is like Fela Fela is
our client at vaynermedia like we
rebooted that brand like that Brea meant
nothing
three years ago and I'm and I understood
that I had more equity in it like that's
what that's my whole Jam my whole Jam is
like why was Marvel comic books bankrupt
but then if you looked at it at a
different angle it was a trillion dollar
movie franchise
why I was feeling something that nobody
gave a [ __ ] about but if you made dad
shoes for girls they [ __ ] took over
why was champion champion four years ago
yeah yeah 49 year old white is so on
that kick on some real [ __ ] made on some
real [ __ ] call it swag call it culture
people [ __ ] like you bro and like you
represent something I if you back to the
players tribute thing if I don't know
what it is I'd be lying if I said I did
but if you do one smart thing that is
the right look and enough people see it
all the [ __ ] that I'm talking about
right now that you're actually sitting
on opens up maybe you know what action
let me let me throw something crazy at
you there's a real big compliment Marky
Mark was Marky Mark but Mark Wahlberg
was an icon the rock was the rock
everybody loved the rock it was a huge
wrestler even people that don't want
wrestling knew who the [ __ ] he was
Dwayne Johnson is a totally different
dude right like The Fresh Prince that
you guys are youngsters The Fresh Prince
of Bel like went The Fresh Prince when I
was a kid was a [ __ ] dope ass rapper
but Will Smith became an icon I swear to
God
that's how I see you [ __ ] I mean I don't
even see myself like that honestly by
the way I know you don't because did
you'd be doing different [ __ ] I
understand that you don't that's why I'm
bringing it up let me give you this is a
make pretend of like how I'm thinking if
you were like the face of like the
breakout iPhone one-on-one game like
John Madden this is a good example John
[ __ ] Madden like had a nice sports
career called football and then some
small [ __ ] gaming company came to him
when video games were different not
checkable John Madden football different
company I technical was the game that
was the game just like I'm bi alive used
to be game and now it's 2k technoboy was
the game and this little company called
EA came to and said we're doing a
football game do you want to be the face
of it he said sure basically that
singular decision changed John Madden's
life financially in the leverage he had
and all of
who knows what he did with it you know
with the wave mobile games work and [ __ ]
like that like if you were the if it was
like Nate Robinson's one on one and that
became the fortnight that would be the
Domino that then would open up
everything else
you understand you say you need to end
by the way the [ __ ] player is reaping
things the big three in a little way
that's flirting with it but you said the
most important thing you said I don't
even see myself that way I know that
because those are the decisions you're
making versus what I would be doing
which is making a lot more content like
like if I were you I'd probably go on
Instagram live for an hour every day my
life and just [ __ ] talk to people
like I want you to have the leverage Ice
Cube has the leverage right Derek Jeter
has the leverage but you have more
actual end consumer natural [ __ ] in you
than both of them I really believe that
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious with you
I can't wait to see like you know you
get me excited just thinking about the
[ __ ] now even more so it's real I mean
because like for me being a father man
there's so many things that I think
about in trying to raise my kids the
right way and you know they want so many
different things and you want to do so
many different things they have so many
different personalities so it's like
managing all that still going out
working hard still going
doing things so it's like trying to
micromanage your life but yet still
trying to live you know that if you know
the big you know the biggest problem is
for you and I is when people grow up
with nothing and they have kids they
want to give their kids too much that's
the number one thing you can do for your
kids is say now you know how are you
secretly think in your head how soft
they are compared to you
[ __ ] you no sleep no [ __ ] secretly
hell you one thing you do for your kids
I'll tell my kids already like 13 is
coming and 13 you're gonna go from real
rich to real poor I'm like I'm not
buying [ __ ] and honestly honestly it's
gonna it's gonna be the thing that makes
them happy because when you're on the
payroll and you're 23 it's over it's
over all right
hey man Thank You Man it's gonna take
any time thank you having me bro do you
got let me take a photo of course let's
go now
I've been like in-between like working
and stuff like a regular job
that doing music and I didn't know like
if I should just and I feel like I
should just speak to the music's grind
it out bro you should live as shitty as
possible and do the music because you
don't have a gret later you can always
get a shitty job you can always paint
you could always work a [ __ ]
Starbucks you could always get a job at
vaynermedia
you need to [ __ ] and see through the
music but what you need to know is when
you're doing that you're signing up or
eating [ __ ] like that those pools need
to go into studio time I'm being serious
bro like if you're gonna see it through
you got a [ __ ] hot commit like you
can't be here right now I'm being
serious like I know like like you know
it's good networking and I get it but
like you got to make the music because
music is amazing now your one song like
their one SoundCloud moment away not
just real life
good working with Justin a bunch of
stuff for you my artist that I manage oh
yeah this is remarkable
this is [ __ ] fresh so bear Walker
designed this for you dude this is
amazing thank you we love your shoes
yo how can you guys ship this look if
you ship it I'll actually I'll actually
give it some real love but I don't want
to upset I don't want to like take it or
not take it - no it's perfect on the
wall man that's that's that's what
that's why I'm saying like ship that to
my office I'll rock is it absolutely can
we get a paper yeah of course great so
let's move you continue to level up and
I see this you've got again the sneakers
tops line Tech's like I could go on it
seems to me that every time I go on
social media Gary showed up with
something right so is the come up easier
than the level up they're the same game
for me and I think for some people the
come up cz err and the level ups harder
for other people it's the reverse for me
you know what it's gonna be a fun recall
the same guy who works the room with the
same level of humility and deep passion
to meet people and help them and help
himself if serendipitously he stumped us
into an opportunity who loves to co-sign
and watch people shine and like why not
who likes to like add to that you know
is it is the same guy today that was
seven years ago and that's the same with
me with wine techs tops like I'm pretty
much navigating the same exact business
blueprint that got me here and I'm a
more mature version I'm in the
subtleties much better than I used to be
but at its core like what you know a lot
of times you hear this saying you know
what got you here is what you need to
double down on and then you hear
contradictions like you got to change up
now that you're the next level I think
people make those things absolute here's
how I see it I'm I'm tripling down on
what got me here but I'm maturing and
evolving around the edges and changing
certain things more mature more
thoughtful not making the same mistakes
and it
you know experienced Gary should be
better than rookie Gary you know where
you end up in your you know you know
career is going to be predicated on many
things and talent is one of them your
ambition is another circumstance you
know all of us if we have a tragic event
check out like there's a million
variables in life but take away lot luck
like you know you know that I do not
play the lottery cuz I'm scared to win
scary win I do not play the lottery
because I'm scared to win because then
everybody will say that it was the
lottery ticket that enabled me to do the
things I'm planning on doing the next 50
years
in Denver digital summit it was a last
shitty greenroom yep that was the moment
that changed my life like that put
everything into motion and I left that
day feeling so rejected yep and just
felt like it like I remember I just got
turned down to it's like I got turned
down for a dream job type scenario and I
went home and looked myself in mirrors
like this guy's range these guys so far
they say there's a small but I'm getting
big enough large percentage of people
who don't like me and it's because of
that thing I don't want to call people
fake entrepreneurs I don't want to say
that they're on Daddy's money I don't
want to say that they're delusional or
lost or have the wrong marketing
strategy that's not fun for me I hate
being disliked I'm a tough guy on camera
and on stage but you see how I act
dinner in real life I'll spend 20
minutes to let somebody they're the
reason that takes me forever to network
is it takes me seven minutes to let them
down kindly there is no you know but I
care to help you like it's why I didn't
Toronto the other day right cuz I'm
watching I'm like oh if you can tweak it
even a little right and you have which
is why so much good is happening you
know the end you know like hungry hunger
is a really interesting thing you know
hunger is interesting thing because when
you're hungry when you get an
opportunity you ten
to over gorge what I think back is like
real quick on this it's a really
important algae that I've never really
I've thought about but I've never said
out loud when you're hungry and you get
to a buffet you throw up and so when
when people are hungry for success and
they get in front of me or anybody else
or an opportunity but they overeat truth
I know it's fine I know you get it and I
think that you're eating a couple less
plates now at you have bats and that's
why things are happening
no thanks bro yeah may I appreciate that
man it's true it's true bro I love you
dude well let me back in 2014 that's
when I found you Gary
yeah 2015 I want to get a tattoo you and
then whenever I met you I'm going to
show you that tattoo you've loved what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
do you have are you getting emotional
bro no I just whatever I see you Gary I
don't say anything you know that's the
respect that I just don't say anything
to say hi hello I met you a couple of
times so do you roll in yep yeah thanks
do I go off the whole way to hold the
whole time but at the end of Damon who
you were kinda like the father I never
had okay really yeah
thank you bro that's really like you
it's so crazy to be at this point in my
life where like now I put enough on film
and audio and wax and whatever you want
to call it that some of this [ __ ] is
starting to happen already like these
conversations are happening already and
I'm like man I'm 43 like yeah I'm latest
[ __ ] for you you're not coming to this
are you the right now okay
[Music]